okay actually oh I played about four
hours of doom eternal a couple weeks ago
and now we can finally talk about it I'm
excited because based on my demo of that
game I really liked it and after talking
to you you said that you really liked
doom 2016 like a bunch of people and you
have good taste so you wanted to know
you had a few questions for me now that
I've played about three and a half to
four hours of doom eternal yes my first
question for you is glory kills which
ones are your favorite which ones do you
remember do you like them more or less
than me
I'm glad you asked because the like one
of the first things I did in this demo
was I mean they kind of like have very
obvious tutorials like again the game is
throwback in a lot of ways but I walked
up to one of the base enemies I don't
know if they changed the names in this
game it was like a basic thrall and I
like did a downward hammer punch on top
of his head and his head went into his
torso and he made one of those faces
like he was kind of simplex like you
know when a cat you put something on a
cat's nose and they kind of sink into
their torso in just in a less violent
way he did that and his face made me
laugh a lot that was one thing about
this demo this game made me laugh a lot
because of how just absolutely decidedly
metal it is that trailer that released
last week with that open with like a
giant pentagram on the earth where like
South America should be that's the whole
game like your York they literally say
you're clearing the demonic presence by
percentages on earth and you're tracking
these hell priests and you have to bring
one of their heads to his brothers - I
don't know I'm not even spoiling
anything because so much happens
yeah and speaking of and I got to talk
to Hugo Martin and Marty Stratton during
like kind of in the middle of my demo
and they were saying that's a big aim
for them is to kind of go all-in on
story which is odd because doom 2016 I
felt was good because it was almost like
an anti narrative like it was like we
don't really need that we just want to
be fun and we have a lot of stuff under
the surface that's gonna make you get
into that flow state in this game you
don't necessarily need us to stop you
for cutscenes
um but this game they're they're really
going into that they they there are
cutscenes and they but they did say like
Hugo's like we made sure like none of
them are gonna be that much longer than
60 seconds if that
we don't want people we don't want to
pull people out of the game which we've
been you know like the the mechanics
which we've been focusing on a ton and
we can get to that but you know like I
ran into other like incidental
characters who weren't just like either
this massive AI villain like at the end
of the 2016 game or but like I ran into
another person from this past battle on
earth and they talked a lot about the
history and like all those diary entries
kind of logs are there I I really like
those from 2016 and I I read like one or
two during my demo but by the nature
that because of the nature that demo is
trying to play as much of the game as
possible but it's there if you want to
if you want to explore that and they
said you know as long as it's not
getting in the way of the players who
want to ignore it then it's fine like
you know they're not trying to please
everybody but if the opportunity arises
to please a ton of people like why not
add some story for the people that
really did like the flavor techs from
the first game and give like an actual
much more fleshed out narrative so plot
aside tell me about the way the combat
is different I mean I've seen in the
trailer that it looks pretty similar and
that you're encouraged to keep moving
around encouraged to switch weapons but
this one I hear that there are a lot
more new weapons and that they really
set you up experiment
yeah that was that was I think a lot of
people's questions and my question going
in was like how do you really improve on
doom 2016 like I'm sure you could like
there were flaws to that game not many
but I found like for instance there was
a bit too much platforming that was kind
of punishing if you just like screwed up
even a tiny bit and there's platforming
this game but it's not it's not
completely punishing when you mess up
and like all that aside they Hugo was
talking about it he's like he's like yes
doom on the surface is junk food and
everybody loves junk food and is there
for a reason it's called junk food for a
reason but like everybody still a lot of
people still like having junk food he's
like we want to make junk food but like
kind of sneak in the nutrition
underneath so he's like we want to make
healthy junk food which sounds like a
paradox and it is but it's doom so it
makes sense they you know like they said
they didn't want to just do more of the
same which again would have been easy
for this game because nukem 2016 was so
solid and refined in its own right but
here they added these mechanics that
aren't just
more they actually kind of revamp how
you move through the world for instance
boom 2016 had obviously the glory kills
would give you health so you'd want to
do those every little bit especially in
harder difficulties and it was really
pushing me to move forward and
assassinate these people so you could
get that health he needed and then
there's also chainsaw kills which would
give you ammo so when you would run low
on ammo which was fairly often in that
game of like ammo is was scarce and it
seemed even more scarce now but they
added something called a flame belch
which is a shoulder-mounted flamethrower
and of course like the name of
everything else that I saw on the demo
is just very absurd and and great and
when you light people on fire as if you
hurt them while they're ablaze you will
get armor so they added that to that
core loop and it seems small but it's
just one other core pillar that you're
kind of thinking about when you're in
that flow state of moving forward maybe
I need a glory kill maybe I need some
ammo oh there's chainsaw fuel go get
that so I can get that ammo oh my armor
slow up in my house fine why don't I
just like these guys on fire and then
throw a frag grenade into the middle of
them or shoot a frag grenade from my
other shoulder into the middle of them
and I'll have a ton of armor and it's
extremely satisfying and the game
constantly did make me switch weapons
which was a huge focus of theirs cuz you
and I were talking earlier the super
shotgun was still I mean it's like the
legacy weapon of the game outside of
like The BFG but they said they're like
we noticed like pretty much the vast
majority people were kind of relying on
it but if not relying on it like
defaulting to it and they said that's
cool look they made a good weapon but
they made a bunch of other good weapons
they wanted to make sure that people are
rotating through them so animal was
super scarce when I was playing during
my demo I was constantly switching from
the rocket launcher to the heavy cannon
to the back to the original auto shotgun
and it felt great to rotate through
those and there was actually like
certain weak points on certain team like
for kakko demon for instance in this
game if you have the grenade launcher
mod equipped to the bottom of your
you're like auto shotgun if you should
have grenade into his mouth he'll do
this like kind of a little choke burp
smoke come out of his mouth but it
automatically every time you do that
sets him up for a glory kill so that
would kind of encourage you
oh I'm I have some Rockets left but a
like a rocket launcher is gonna be the
best weapon if it's flying enemy I'm
gonna switch to that and then I need a
glory kill so I'm gonna switch to my
auto shock and it was very good at
encouraging me to use my entire toolset
but it was also very fun to use my
entire toolset and I think that's
difficult to do because a lot of
old-school games have weapon wheels and
you know like it's obviously doom 2016
got away was one of the few games with
one of the games to get away from that
to weapon loadout that Call of Duty kind
of made ubiquitous like more than a
decade ago
but it felt great to kind of just try
out everything my disposal they also I
got an ice bomb which freezes enemies
and it's very useful I got something
there's something they add it called a
blood punch basically I forget how many
it's like I think three or four if you
do three or four glory kills you fill up
this meter and so your next melee attack
doesn't have to be a glory kill but your
next melee attack pretty much you hit
one enemy and this a OE explosion just
like turns everybody else around you
into blood and it kills them wait so
everybody around yep II mean like the
Laura and lower-level enemies yes but
just in general even if there are
higher-level enemies around it'll just
do a lot of AoE damage
so you'll notice like the screen will
flash red and kind of flash or like
brighten and then everybody around you
will either die or just get very much
hurt but then that that's another way
hey like I I don't necessarily need
health but I have this blood punch and
I'm about to run out of ammo and there's
a kakko demon right there that I think
is almost at lower like no health so
I'll use that and it felt like it
totally made sense what he's saying it
did feel like healthy junk food it's
like I'm just having a blast I'm
laughing at all the absurd jokes in this
game and how confident it is and like
how self-aware it is yet still willing
to take itself seriously if not like you
know not in a narcissistic way but in a
way that's like if it feels like it
knows what it's doing obviously the game
just felt great I walked away it was it
was four hours of a much larger game and
that the game is larger its sprawling
like when you see the map you download
the map data kind of like going back to
obviously boom 2016 but back to like the
Super Metroid days and you have to find
the map data to download you I opened my
map and I was like amazed at how
sprawling it wasn't there's a hub world
where you go back to your your fortress
to kind of you get a training area kind
of like they had it in like a second row
when you could challenge that immortal
guy just to try out all your new your
tools and your abilities and
and it's it's I asked them why they add
I was like I feel like a hub world is
kind of par for the course in like
modern games now obviously games service
it makes sense to have one where there's
like an MMO space or where you're
collecting a lot of things to keep like
obviously they're collectibles in Doom
2016 but in the sense that are just like
cosmetics you're collecting they're like
we get that but the game is so sprawling
and we did kind of want to give you a
sense of a place that could be familiar
because the game is so large and you're
gonna be if you really want to invest in
it or whether you're like platinum in it
or whatever you want to what have you we
still wanted to give you a spot that
would be familiar and where you could
train or where you could you know like
just come back to and maybe you want to
do a few upgrades there what you can do
upgrades on the fly but it wasn't it was
it was like a it seemed like a pretty
well designed hub world it didn't seem
entirely necessary to me but again I
only played four hours of the game so
maybe like after a while it will get it
seems like I could get overwhelming in a
sense like how much there is to explore
it's not an open world I want to be
clear I'm not saying that but it's still
that linear firefights but they kind of
like branch out on these larger Maps and
of course like the hub world will also
allow them to have that familiarity
because you are going to so many
different like environments locales so
to speak I never left earth in the demo
now that I think of it but it does seem
like if you wanted to invest all your
time into getting all these collectibles
which are which it encourages you to do
because a lot of them are just like
crazy upgrades that allow you to shoot
three rockets at once for the cost of
one surprisingly forgiving consider I
felt like in the first one I was always
vulnerable in some way like sure even if
I'm progressing my skills or reloading I
still felt like right at any moment
something was probably me yeah it it was
kind of it from what I saw it mainly
just happens at the end of missions so
it's kind of like the bookend for
missions or the interlude until you get
into that yeah that very unsafe until
you get into that very unsafe area and
whether whatever the next locale might
be and I didn't really get to experience
the overall flow of mission hub world
mission hub world
I went to the hub world after I got the
ice bomb or right before I got the ice
bomb and I was about to get the super
shotgun before the end of my demo but
the game kind of has this like wink it's
like you're about to jump and get it's
like that rotating green pickup and then
all of a sudden like this door closes
and you it's it's clear it's gonna be
like a mission to get it which is kind
of it feeds into what they were saying
like we don't want people just to rely
on one gun and again the game it's even
if it's one thing to say they don't want
people do that but it's one thing to
make a game that actually encouraged you
to use the entire toolset and from my
you know three or four hours it really
felt like it did and I left excited to
see what was gonna happen in the next
four hours and for after that so overall
what would you say are the top three
improvements from June 2016 to to the
eternal okay I would say the first one
is how they managed to expand the
toolset without just like piling things
on top its they've had a depth to it
that kind of just like so much of what I
enjoyed about this game was on a
subconscious level to the point where
that was one of the few demos I've done
in a while sometimes those can be kind
of you know it's it's PR II obviously
they're doing their job but it's also
like us going like okay well I don't
want to speak too much to this the
overall quality of game that was
definitely a game I've played where I
left still kind of like I wasn't even
just thinking about what I played I was
still kind of like feeling it the muscle
memory which is kind of crazy but also
very cool also on this oh wait oh yeah
no I I am blood punch anybody number two
I would have to say is I do like the
fact that they're expanding the story
passed just flavor text I'm one of those
people who thinks if a game tells a
story through its systems whatever you
don't need to have like an air like a
plot like a script on top of it
it seems like they understand that of
any company developer to understand that
it would probably be the one I do like
that they're expanding it didn't get in
the way again none of the cutscenes were
long where I was like okay I'm I had my
like hand like on the mouse and keyboard
ready to start playing the whole
cutscenes I didn't really know it's not
like it's surprised cut back to playing
but it was very much you know we know
you want to keep playing but we also
have some cool context what's going on
here and three I love just oddly enough
how hilarious that game is it is just
even if you're not into like death metal
at
to trip storytelling it's still just so
confident in itself and it bleeds over
and it it just kind of like brainwashes
you to be on board with anything it's
doing and I'm it's only from four hours
I can't speak to the overall album less
maybe something terrible happens halfway
through in the game just doesn't work
highly doubt that's the case but if it
did like even those first four hours
would be a game I very much would like
to return to and I'm looking forward to
it in March